oh hi there I'm Greg oh hi there I'm Jan
I've been staring at you reviewing a
reaction video for the Super Mario
Odyssey at the Nintendo switch
presentation but before we do that I
want to overshadow that today's video
sponsor 1up box I've been receiving box
from 1up box for quite some time and
today I decided you know what I'm going
to start opening some of these boxes
yeah I opened the boxes today there's
some great stuff in here today I'm going
to promote the month that was adventure
2 in the month of adventure to a game
with some awesome cool stuff Oh tell us
about it because once a month you can
get a box for $13 becomes a lot of cool
[ __ ] that's worth more to $13 yes that
is awesome
mushroom bow tied at the bow ties that
had just socks of Mario Stefanik Zelda
known as Mario
okay the triangle yep yep that's when
Mario saves Princess Peach from Ganon Oh
serious note we got is awesome
everything else is alright but then go
on is that such [ __ ] and then I would
like to give you a present wait what
ever wear this shirt because blue is not
my color look at this shirt I give to
Dan for coming on the channel thing I
know I pay a lot of money for 1up box
and I get a quarter of it so there's a
link in the description box a referral
link to go buy a 1up box don't worry I
don't get any compensation for it and I
throw the moustache telling my lies
they're not neutralizing telling a
businesslike let's do it I'm ready I'm
not running it's like the new Mario game
yes okay there's the newest blend you
wish Mario should have asked that yeah
sweet look at the graphic Mario's in the
New York I guess my life it's weird
why it's just like it looks good boys
amongst like humans and taxi
what's a Howard I mean I love Mario
we're whoa look at Mach boys is like a
totally different place now
[Music]
so he's like all over the world yet
honestly yeah there you go to pass me
that's cool
[Music]
an hour isn't real Mario's level
well are we though okay well I guess
he's throwing frying pans and maybe the
small thing that is traveling up the
losing her up is up illumining because
called that's it's weird
[Music]
this is gaming that had no idea even
even that cool oh yeah I like that got
like a boomerang I really like Ed not to
me oh hell yeah man I can't even tell
what I'm looking at
[Music]
wow there's a lot of adventure such
adventure y-yeah
what was the wot Mario game last one I
play with sunshine Super Mario 3d World
was the last 3d Mario okay yeah I beat
sunshine how's it go sunshine
yes sunshine Super Mario Sunshine for
Game two doesn't after n64 right yeah I
know
looks Mario that you do W all worried I
know it's a little it's a little strange
it's what he is in right New York
anything like other humans and it's
established that Mario's a [ __ ] yep
and you have the mean adorable together
is that it twice the size alive it is
kind of strange with me II know he's
Italian who's going to be in New York
I mean what's true or authentic Italians
are born everybody not Italy this scheme
have a beginning middle and end
no okay so we know Bowser's gonna do a
thing Bowser doesn't like Mario Bowser
wants to destroy Mario teaches in danger
at some point and then Mario travels the
world while doing all this obsession is
awesome new invention yeah I don't
really know what the let's see the plot
here well I mean a Mario game is not
going to be known for its plot it's
going there's still a lot what doesn't
make sense it's like why we're leaving
the Mushroom Kingdom
and going to [ __ ] do yo yeah yeah what
do you not like about this see that's
the thing is like there's nothing that I
really dislike about it because it looks
fun I don't know what's going on but I'm
along for the ride when I first saw
Mario in New York my first thought was
when they put Sonic with real people and
Sonic Adventure 1 and we all know how
that went
maybe not you but it went I know
everything I know it's a Mario game
I know it's
really fun the hack mechanic is super
cool that was cool
I'm just trying to figure out like how
the platforming fits into this because
Mario is always kind of had like very I
don't want to say simple platforms of
very obvious platforms where it's like
here's where you're going and you kind
of jump up that this is like alright
you're in New York go this could be the
definition of open world come home
literally the whole world Mario open
world Zelda hat I mean he's traveling
like everywhere going everywhere going
real places and completely fixation ibly
that'll work fictional places yeah
fictitious fictitious dictation went to
low red fruit point it looks like it
looks like it's fun Mario game look it
looks super fun and so like I'm not not
going to be like I don't like this game
in a wonít be a part of it I will buy
the [ __ ] out of this game because I need
to know what's happening it still looks
like classic Mario I'm just a crazy new
adventure it seems like it'd be very
hard for me to see people actually
disliking this game what could this game
do that you can actually make you
dislike it it's a very good question I
don't know yeah they're always solid
yeah
like even like mario sunshine with panda
when it first came out as being met but
like now there's a really big cult
following of sunshine and it's like you
can't go wrong with the mario game so
whatever they're doing there will be
good I just feel like this game be
awesome felt like on shrooms or
something to choose right imagine me on
shrooms appointment game what would it
be a little overloaded yeah what do you
guys think of the Mario game huh what
you put in comments below YouTube
questions you can hit the subscribe
button for this channel do it I say that
with a lot of confidence you do Dan
cyber you can subscribe to this guy
that's cyber channel and he's that cyber
guy on Instagram and Twitter
it is a gamer this [ __ ] yeah and
he also string he's going to be doing
streaming with it what Daisy streaming
on Wednesdays at 3:30 on youtube.com
slash user slash games I feel like more
people would sleep with me if I look
like this right well I know I would
going on [ __ ] me Mario oh my god my
ratings keep you bras on sup yeah I do
plumbing who the [ __ ] cares us we'll
save this one [ __ ] every year name
speech what what do you get my lawyer
gets kidnapped by this [ __ ] weird
reptile yeah yeah videos right rap top I
like a turtle yeah I guess so make a
turtle dinosaur thing yeah and it's poop
it's pretty cool I'm gonna Gayle older
brother